and welcome to new racket game yanli
chess-playing Higashi
Higashi no further information on him I
will light a three and don't have any
water which is not a good way to start a
game with but hasn't you played yet
right now replace ya see for ng3 I play
both so let's go see for play this a bit
more frequently nowadays but g3 also
served me quite well over the years the
main difference is that after g3 against
Kings Indian like g3 g6 you are promoted
to the second oh yeah by t3 like now has
a ton taller options this is one of this
one and III use one of the possible
moves
I have played almost anything in this
position 54 anything everything and now
you probably will wonder about this move
but I'm actually taking with the do pawn
I know that looks extremely boring but
it is kind of interesting this is what
something is an idea that recently and
was played in Grandmaster chess I kind
of I try to recall who played it said so
moshevsky and I don't know one very
highly regarded to theoretician platters
and the idea is to play you for Bishop
III it to understand this idea you have
to be aware that eform
takes pawn take D takes Queen d1 King
bee one is considered to be very
comfortable for white as we should be
three attacks topology of easy play on
the Queen side and I have this now
basically a temple down I will play a 3d
form g6 is actually not good normally
because this is a misplaced Bishop on g7
the bishop is much better on f8 and then
on e7 two to cover the condemn but okay
we'll see if you'll see what happens
should be three come ahead 95
I could have take 95 already just
snatching the bishop pair almost
lecturing the bishop bishop panel unless
maybe he has something funky against
this wow what is that
I mean b3 is not a move that I need to
play by every time but I don't mind
playing it okay so here 95 comes into
consideration which it takes there
should be five check normal is just 92
of course I'm going to play 92 this is a
very comfortable situation actually c5
is currently under check he has to cover
this normal would be six but yeah okay
so here I wonder if I should go away for
immediately I think I think I want to do
this and tending Bishop b5 I would like
to trade the light squared bishop the
general issue for black here is that the
pawn on c5 is on a dark square and he's
got the dark squared Bishop on g7 sorry
but I have eight potentially under seven
and I have some some ways of putting
slight pressure on that Queen side
really okay so he allows a five okay he
cannot go b5 anyway so I don't need to
play a five in the first place
okay I'll start with f3 this move is
something I have to play anyway to make
my light mobile again I shouldn't play
to a 5 he has b6 now now cadets also not
super enjoyable
if you have an idea what this move is
about please tell me I don't know what
this is about
94 intending 95 is interesting or just a
five Wow
I'm a little bit uncertain I mean I have
this the sunshine she wants to play g5
which would be pretty strange but it
could be that this is Plex idea and we
go c6
okay so I guess tonight's you form
keeping v6 under attack on any b5 I have
nine eighty five one idea can also be to
the sacrifice on the seven secretary
exchange and then we'll be 625 basically
win the whole queenside now here I can
donate a three and force him back if I
want to do that I don't know if I want
to but this looks looks fine down you
have the sacrificial idea gets
interesting now and will win many pawns
Fischer therefore I can also move the
night which then he has to basically as
to basically play okay seven Bishop f4
is also interesting I asked to move the
dead again
hmm t5 is terrible so you have to move
the hook again there's also a t5 be 596
also an idea who interesting if I look
at the night again he has to probably
claim up to a seven but I don't have a
good have a really good square night a
three book is heaven doesn't look like
it Nets much and Bishop f4
taking on this happening and I'm not
sure about it is some compensation but I
don't know if it is enough okay so it
looks good but it's not not totally
obvious what I should do
can Bishop f4 wait and we should f4 I
wonder if I have some kind of Knight b6
IDM we should therefore move the loop
then a fire hmm and it isn't isn't
totally clear
there should be a 493 to d5 it would be
good at the temple move 187 okay
then I was a bit too long um I mean I
can't claim any move that give me some
kind of an advantage and I think I
probably took a bit too long I know any
place at 85 somehow laughter but I don't
I don't think so if I was a to terrible
so we have to move the rook but way I'm
b7 so now I move the knight he has to
cover this and b5 he cannot play so he
has to go back with the rook and then I
have 95 I don't know it looks a little
bit lame everything it looks at a claim
okay taking actually interesting King
takes rook t1 but then Keaney ADA's is
enough okay so lightly three forces rook
is 7 I think
b5 a tick and that killed him on the 8th
also ok 7 and 95
oh oh oh oh I'm sorry but this is kind
of shocking really
that's it strategically a strategic
suicide almost and so we should be hive
immediately or I think this is better
first first put the rope onto a seven i
play Bishop b5 next and straightest and
then 94 and Wow these success is going
to be terminally week I think kind of
surprised the teeth take someone there
maybe can play we should know Bishop e5
now 57 kills black 95 is terrible and
they have 1994's my next move unless he
attacks something is there a DD force is
interesting in okay but I can just play
94 no no need for anything fancy b6 is
weak and we see that too many pawns on
dark squares especially the basic spawn
is a problem okay
[Music]
can even think about playing before here
just just prying everything open you
just feel a little bit to rush to this
decision oh I don't think so
I'm going to pile up more we should have
six is not quite clear to me what this
does mean castling was difficult anyway
but now it's impossible 95 looks looks
devastating
pawn takes rook takes threatening look
a8 and what is smooth then five or so
it looks it looks pretty devastating but
is there any defense yeah I think I'm a
little bit reluctant to sacrifice on a
five because this position will win
itself basically with technical means so
it's a little bit feels a little bit
weird to sacrifice something when you
don't have to
so check
it's completely it's totally killing so
let's do it
oh okay seven I have 96 oh that's lucky
I didn't even consider okay seven well I
have 96 oops
most bad yeah actually I should have
seen that
yeah I'm reading this the mating attack
don't see a way to defend it I think
hello
a hive or something yeah so I can check
I didn't calculate this this far
actually I'm just thinking that this
must be winning anyway
yeah the check on it it looks kind of
normal I just wonder if there's
something better I can also take of
course Bishop e5 so check King to e7 and
then taking on c5 a little bit strange
should be three probably am i cannot
move anything it's it's really funny
King e7 Bishop e3 I just wonder quickly
if there's something else I don't think
so this is good yeah
I actually overlooked you know what I
overlooked 96 I can just play 96 I was
thinking he cannot move the night as
Uruk is unprotected which is of course
ridiculous oh that's not good huh I
played this really badly this is what I
meant with the sacrifice you know that
position was technically very trivially
winning you just have to slowly slowly
move forward and black is completely
completely doing and now I've looked
some some detail which was a detailer it
was simple to to see and now this isn't
it isn't even clear
it isn't even clear that's pretty
terrible my take here I've got three
pawns but it says a double pawn and this
isn't isn't a clear situation at all
that's totally ridiculous quickly given
how simply winning this position was so
I should have just played technically or
I don't know focus a little bit more not
or we looked at this is the simple stuff
that this is protected all day now this
game is continuing and it's not even
clear that I'm better the pawns are
dangerous I mean his bishop is not
exactly great on h8 but we are quite
quite obviously that was a huge blunder
sometimes she really won them
[Music]
hmm
my book doesn't have many squares to go
to I can't start with the king
pretty funny Bishop on aged aid then
extremely funny piece so I wonder just
kiss you 45 or something I can actually
run to a five and move the beep on that
is interesting I mean he takes takes a
while until this is coming okay
and each other
I don't know it might still be good for
white the pants are not strong but the
whole the whole action was totally
totally totally unnecessary maybe the
sacrifice was good at the at them at the
start and then I screwed it up that's
it's possible
we should have six or something maybe
be 6:58 would be five
I have to have to watch out there and
I'm not running into some ridiculous
self-made c4 first no time piece
explicitly a droopy five look d1 okay
six I can run all the way to b7 to know
this really helps if five is also
hanging then I don't know and I've
really screwed this up that's the kind
of that's really really I'm really upset
about this because the game was such a
clear-cut ham without the sacrifice
again it's just technically very trivial
we can look at this a little bit in
Indian Alice's maybe this is some not
totally obvious to you how easy that
would be about the word sacrifice
look d3 maybe I can take a five
so ka 6 maybe this is wrong okay King
bee 7 I probably cannot allow so let's
do it let's do it
so just you fall here or and cannot
leave the room at the moment the King
makes no sense
lucky for me sometimes you can just do
it like that
yeah this is so and I thought rook t5
might win
maybe not think things
c5 takes c6
you
cakes on e46 look c4 is the thing but I
have some work ta own see putting in
good soup fun it would be terrible
I can I can actually do the [ __ ] hook
before a one trying to run around to see
602 d1 at the end look f1 and maybe look
everyone
you probably take a form and then I'm
not able to penetrate yes look fYI look
before
how is he doing this now look before
again I'm not sure when I'm threatening
you
look you one is looking for probably
[Music]
sure
very not sure why this position I cannot
go b7 c7 doesn't threaten all that much
still I'm not sure and now I can go to
q1 d7 it doesn't have wood before
anymore when I'm not sure of course the
time situation is making it difficult we
should see five or so
this is going to be my first lost in
this in this town control here on HS and
it's from a position that was so utterly
winning unbelievable now I should have
just just not sacrificed and play the
automatic win there's a bit of a joke to
lose this game
okay we'll see afterwards
okay yeah that was pretty terrible
I mean I could have drawn at the end of
everything but it's this is not the
thing the thing is that this wasn't
totally one-sided game a black slate and
pretty pretty terribly and you just have
to just have to win technically and
don't do any fancy box and okay so when
yeah white already has a pretty nice
position here but it got good to a
substantial advantage with moves like a
six and so on I am and if I was shocking
is is a shockingly bad move after this
white is just strategically winning so
look here and now okay I mean the
sacrifices win and it's not very
surprising but you can just win the
automatic moves look you won or whatever
I mean like cannot leave anything it's a
complete complete disaster and this does
win of course but it's not necessary I
can take if I am okay and again taking
five I just had a total I had a total
brain slap here that brain slip that he
can play ninety-six I was just not aware
that the look is protected so this is
also winning because I really cannot
remove this stuff and I'm sorry for us
and this is over it took took a lot of
crap moves to among to do to lose the
game in this position is better for
white of course but you're probably not
winning anymore and I think I had a win
in the game but I mean the posture that
solves a pretty certain so keen lofty
five is winning
and just do this and see for and over
well that's simply that's so simple I
mean wow wow
and it seems to win as well but I'll
screw it up later
so so far and just Ruby five and UPA it
wins okay now and now I looped wrong and
it gets tough it's still it's still a
job due to the corner return
Gaddis seems to this seems to lose that
it didn't Devon to exploit it down
yeah is this Bishop c5 I overlook I mean
I didn't have much time at this at this
moment but so I should play c7 habit by
now I was really unsettled because I
mean you can absolutely not lose this
game but I actually I probably shouldn't
sacrifice on e5 objectively it's good
might be six seems to be a little bit
better you it's the yeah I did it that
makes some sense yeah this looks a
little bit better but again you you also
just win by playing playing like normal
moves like this also
I mean Black has no moose here 996 I
just go anywhere doesn't matter
and like is running all it moves in this
position what is he doing here again we
can play a couple of moves what the
engine suggests here this is this is a
funny one fix up the b-pawn or here yeah
h4 maybe h4 if you can also just ask him
what what is movers or maybe go h4 GAF 4
and so on
it should be H 2 G 3 D 5 and so on but
ok objectively this is good you had to
sacrifice it just ends the game and I
just have to take five it seems I had a
complete completes a brain slip I was
thinking it cannot move on I attend
anyway it was an interesting game thanks
for watching